لم يكن لدى دونالد جون ترامب أي رئيس آخر هذا
العدد الكبير من كبار المساعدين السابقين الذين قاموا بمثل هذه
التقييمات العامة القاسية، وكان آخرهم
كاسيدي هاتشينسون. أعتقد أن دونالد
ترامب
هو التهديد الأكبر الذي سنواجهه
لديمقراطيتنا في حياتنا
وربما في التاريخ الأمريكي، فهي
تنضم إلى  الجوقة المتزايدة أعتقد أنه
غير لائق للمنصب، فهو دائمًا ما يضع
مصالحه الخاصة ويرضي غروره
قبل أي شيء آخر،
واليوم، رئيس أركان ترامب السابق الأطول خدمة،
جون كيلي، يتناغم
مع انتقاداته القاسية حتى الآن في
بيان حصري لـCNN كيلي  يقول
عن ترامب ما الذي يمكنني إضافته والذي لم
يُقال بالفعل عندما اتصل بالرئيس
ترامب اقتبس من شخص ليس لديه أي فكرة عما
تمثله أمريكا وليس لديه أي فكرة
عما تمثله أمريكا
للمرة الأولى على الإطلاق، يضع كيلي الأمور في نصابها
الصحيح عندما يسجل
تأكيد عدد من
التفاصيل الدامغة حول دونالد ترامب من
مصادر خلفية
بما في ذلك من قصة أتلانتيك لعام 2020
تم الإبلاغ عنها بمصادر غير مسماة من قبل
رئيس التحرير جيفري غولدبرغ
بما في ذلك التفاصيل المذهلة التي
وجهها ترامب إلى كيلي في يوم الذكرى في
مقبرة أرلينغتون الوطنية في عام 2017 و
سألني لا أفهم ما الذي كان يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة
لهم،
هذا هو كيلي الذي يؤكد على
القصص المسجلة عن إهانة ترامب للسيناتور جون
ماكين والرئيس السابق جورج بوش
الأب لأنه في فيتنام وفي الحرب العالمية
الثانية على التوالي، تم إسقاط الطيارين السابقين،
يصف كيلي  ترامب على حد تعبير
شخص يعتقد أن أولئك الذين يدافعون عن
بلادهم بالزي العسكري أو يتم إطلاق النار عليهم
أو إصابتهم بجروح خطيرة في القتال أو
يقضون سنوات يتعرضون للتعذيب كأسرى
جميعهم مغفلون لأنه لا يوجد
شيء في ذلك بالنسبة لهم كشخص
لا يريد ذلك  يمكن رؤيته بحضور
مبتوري الأطراف العسكريين لأن الاقتباس
لا يبدو جيدًا بالنسبة لي، الشخص الذي
أظهر ازدراءًا صريحًا
لعائلة النجم الذهبي لجميع عائلات النجم الذهبي
على شاشة التلفزيون خلال حملة عام 2016 والصراخ
بأغلى الأبطال الذين قدموا
حياتهم  الذين يعيشون في الدفاع عن أمريكا هم
خاسرون ولن يزوروا
قبورهم في فرنسا كيلي يؤكد بشكل
رسمي قصة وردت في كتاب
المقسم حيث يقول ترامب لكيلي إنه يريد
عرضًا عسكريًا مثل العرض الذي شاهده في
يوم الباستيل في فرنسا إلا أنه يفعل ذلك
لا أريد أن
يؤكد كيلي أن ترامب في عام 2018 في
فرنسا رفض زيارة قبور
الأمريكيين الذين قتلوا في الحرب العالمية الأولى لشبكة CNN، ووصف
كيلي ترامب بأنه منافق قائلاً
إنه اقتباس غير صادق فيما يتعلق
بموقفه بشأن حماية الحياة التي لم تولد بعد
للنساء في الأقليات  على
المسيحيين الإنجيليين على اليهود على
الرجال والنساء العاملين
ويخلص إلى أن ترامب هو اقتباس شخص
ليس لديه سوى ازدراء
مؤسساتنا الديمقراطية ودستورنا
وسيادة القانون ويخلص إلى أنه لا يوجد شيء
آخر يمكن قوله،
فليساعدنا الله،
فهو يفعل  عمل رائع كرئيس للأركان،
وهو رفض مذهل من قبل رجل
عمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع ترامب لفترة أطول
من أي من رؤساء الأركان العديدين الآخرين في عهد ترامب،
كما انتقد كيلي ترامب لقوله
إن رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة السابق
الجنرال مارك ميلي يجب
إعدامه في قضية  خطاب المغادرة يوم الجمعة
أجاب ميلي أننا لا نقسم
لملك أو ملكة، يا له من طاغية أو
دكتاتور، ولا نقسم
لدكتاتور متمني، بعض الأشخاص الذين
يعرفون دونالد ترامب أفضل
تحذير الآن منه  التهديد الذي يعتقدون أنه
يشكله إذا تم انتخابه في نوفمبر 2024.
الآن تواصلت CNN مع
حملة ترامب بعد ظهر الاثنين لإخبار
المسؤولين في الحملة أن
مسؤولًا سابقًا في الإدارة قد أكد بشكل
رسمي عددًا من التفاصيل حول
قصة مجلة أتلانتيك لعام 2020 التي
لم نقم بها.  اسم جون كيلي ولكننا أردنا أن نرى
تعليقًا حول جوهر تلك
القصة، ردت حملة ترامب
ببيان يهين شخصية ومصداقية
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة المتقاعد الجنرال مارك ميلي الذي
لا علاقة له بالقصة التي
أصدرتها حملة ترامب أيضًا  بيان
يهينني قائلاً إنه يجب عليّ أن أقتبس التوقف عن
الترويج لأخبار مزيفة من مصادر مشبوهة
والتي قد تكون ذات صلة باستثناء أن
الأخبار حقيقية تمامًا والمصدر لا تشوبه شائبة
تمامًا، أود إحضار
شخص عمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع جون كيلي
مستشار الأمن القومي الأمريكي السابق
جون بولتون أه جون، شكرًا لانضمامك
إلينا، ولأول مرة، جون كيلي
الذي كان مترددًا جدًا في القيام بذلك بشكل
رسمي، لكنه هنا يؤكد
العديد من القصص التي أساءت إليه
بشدة،
خاصة تلك التي كانت لها علاقة
بموقفه تجاه المحاربين القدامى
المصابين  جنود يقتلون جنودًا بوق
مقبرة أرلينغتون عام 2017 يقفون
بين قبور الجنود الأمريكيين
الذين ماتوا في أفغانستان والعراق
ويقولون لا أفهم ما كان
لهم من وصف الأمريكيين الذين ماتوا في
الحرب العالمية الأولى بالخاسرين وعدم رفض
زيارة  مقابر الحرب العالمية الأولى أه
جنود ترامب لا يريد الخشب للمحاربين
القدامى في عرض عسكري لأنه
سيقتبس ليس نظرة جيدة له
هل سمعت أيًا من هذه التعليقات أو
أي شيء مثلها وهل لديك أي
سبب للشك في جون كيلي  أعرفه
كما تفعل
جيدًا أولاً، ليس لدي أي سبب على
الإطلاق للشك فيما قاله جون، أعتقد أنه كان
يقول بالضبط ما سمعه من ترامب،
بعض تلك الأشياء التي أخبرني بها،
وبعضها حدث قبل وصولي إلى
البيت الأبيض، أه ال  سؤال أه
يوم المحاربين القدامى أه
الاحتفال بيوم الهدنة في فرنسا أه أنا
لم أسمع تلك التعليقات هناك أعتقد
أنني متأكد من أن جون سمعها عندما كنت
خارج الغرفة أه أفعل شيئًا آخر
ليس لدي أي شك  آه أن ما
قاله جون كيلي كان صحيحًا، لا شيء مهما كانت
تعليقات كيلي تتوافق أيضًا مع
التقارير الواردة من المحيط الأطلسي، وهي
قصة أحدث بقلم جيف جولدبيرج، ملف تعريف
للجنرال ميلي آه أن ترامب لم يكن
رد فعله جيدًا لرؤية
كابتن الجيش الذي أصيب بجروح بالغة آه والذي كان  الغناء "الله
يبارك أمريكا" في حدث في هذه
القصة الأحدث التي كتبها غولدبرغ من الملف الشخصي
لميلي ترامب قال لميلي لماذا
تجلب أشخاصًا مثل هؤلاء إلى هنا، لا أحد
يريد أن يرى هذا الجرحى،
يجب أن أقول على المستوى الشخصي  كشخص
يحاول القيام بالكثير من العمل لمساعدة
جنودنا الجرحى أه أه أنا لا
أفهم حتى وجهة النظر هذه، هؤلاء هم
أشجع الشجعان لدينا وكان هذا الرجل
قائدًا أعلى للقوات المسلحة ويريد أن يصبح
القائد-  القائد الأعلى مرة أخرى وهو لا
يريد رؤية
الجنود الجرحى
أشرح لي ذلك، إذا استطعت،
يمكنني أن أخبرك بما أخبرني به جون كيلي ذات مرة
عن الزيارة إلى والتر ريد
التي تمت قبل وصولي
عندما يرى معظم الناس  أفراد الخدمة الذين
أصيبوا بجروح خطيرة
يتأثرون بها أو يذهلون من
التفاني في أداء الواجب والوطنية وتفاني
أولئك الذين
ضحوا كثيرًا وتحملوا مثل هذه
الجروح الوحشية التي قال ترامب إنه حاول
الابتعاد عنها وفسرها جون كيلي
أعتقد بشكل صحيح أنه
جبن من جانب ترامب، خوفًا من أن
شيئًا كهذا قد يحدث
له، وهو
لا
يريد مواجهته، أنا لست طبيبًا نفسيًا، ولا
أجري تشخيصات طبيب نفسي، ولكن أعتقد
الجبن أه التحليل أجنبي صحيح